how do you control an airplane in this
video I'm going to explain the basics of
how an airplane is controlled by the
pilot and how the flight controls move
the airplane around its three main
axes welcome to Free pilot training I'm
Josh and today I'm talking to you about
controlling your airplane because in
order to build a good foundation for
your flight training you've got to
understand how the flight controls work
and how you can use them to move the
airplane around its three main a
unlike a car or a truck an airplane is
able to move into three dimensions it's
able to move into these three different
dimensions because it rotates around its
center of gravity on three different
axes the lateral axis the longitudinal
axis and the vertical axis we're going
to be discussing each one of those in
detail but if you're taking notes you're
going to want to remember these for the
written exam and speaking of that this
video that you're watching is part of my
complete and totally free Private Pilot
ground course here on YouTube but in
order order to take the FAA written exam
you've got to be endorsed by an improved
instructor so if you're going to be
taking that written exam you can buy the
premium version of this course which
includes an endorsement reading
assignments and quizzes that'll ensure
that you're completely ready to take
that test because believe me it's a bear
but don't worry these videos will get
you ready and that premium course will
make doubly sure that you pass the exam
with flying colors and that's available
for only $50 on free pilot trining
Donnet look around most courses are
going to cost you closer to $300 but
anyway let's get back to talking about
these three axes now I briefly mentioned
this a second ago but it's important to
remember that all three of these axes go
through the center of gravity and when
your airplane moves it rotates around
the center of gravity on that axis but
what the heck is the center of gravity
in a nutshell the center of gravity is a
theoretical point where the weight of an
aircraft is concentrated in other words
if I were to hang an airplane on a
string by its center of gravity the
airplane would be balanced perfectly and
it would just stay like this as long as
we didn't move any weight around and if
we move some weight up closer to the
front the center of gravity would move
forward as well and the nose would tilt
down on you now it's important to note
that an airplane doesn't actually
balance on its center of gravity it
actually balances on something called
the center of lift and the center of
lift is a theoretical point where all
the lift that a wing produces is
concentrated in other words this is the
spot where we balance an airplane when
we're flying so if we were put the
center of gravity directly beneath the
center of lift the airplane would just
chill here perfectly balanced but we
don't do that we actually put the center
of gravity in front of the center of
lifts so the nose of your airplane is
actually really heavy I'll explain why
we do that in a future episode but for
now all you need to know is that an
airplane moves around its center of
gravity on its three axes okay now that
you know that let's take a look at each
individual axis the first way an
airplane moves is on its lateral axis
some Pilots refer to to this as the
pitch axis because we move an airplane
around its lateral axis by pitching the
nose of the aircraft up or down now
here's where things get kind of weird by
pitching the nose up and down the
aircraft is actually moving
longitudinally around that lateral axxis
now in my old video I had a ton of
people questioning that statement yes
the airplane moves longitudinally around
the lateral axis the airplane moves
perpendicular to the axis that you're
rotating on does that make sense comment
below if you're still having a hard time
with that now how do we move our
airplane around that lateral axis well
to pitch the nose up and down we have to
use the elevator and to control the
elevator on our aircraft we have to use
the yolk or the stick if your airplane
has one of those pulling back on the Yol
raises your elevator and by raising the
elevator in Flight the tail is deflected
downward and that rotates our aircraft
up around the lateral axis if we push
forward on the Yol that lowers the
elevator and that deflects the tail
upward which rolls us down around that
lateral axis and if that's too
complicated remember this trees get
bigger trees get smaller that ought to
learn you and that's how simple it is to
move an aircraft longitudinally around
its lateral axis now let's talk about
the longitudinal axis this is what most
Pilots refer to as the roll axis and
that's because we roll the airplane
around that axis now remember this axis
goes through the center of gravity the
entire length of the airplane that's why
we call it the longitudinal axis but the
actual movement is perpendicular to that
axis just like the other one we just
talked about so when an airplane moves
around its longitudinal axis it's moving
laterally around that longitudinal axis
have I confused you
yet yeah you did I hope not I want you
guys to get this we're going to be
building on all this information now how
do we move laterally around that roll
axis what controls do we need to use if
you said Aeron you're absolutely correct
just like the elevator the aerons are
one of the primary flight controls that
we use as Pilots to control the aircraft
aerons are kind of interesting these are
tied together in such a way that by
rotating the Yol one Aeron is raised
while the other one is lowered the
aileron that is lowered creates more
lift while the Aeron that is raised
creates less lift this in turn rolls the
aircraft in whatever Direction the pilot
wants we'll talk more about this in a
future video but for now all you need to
do is remember that the aerons roll the
aircraft along its longitudinal axis
last but not least let's talk about the
vertical axis some Pilots refer to this
as the yaw axis now why is that cuz it's
so boring it makes you yawn not exactly
yaw is simply another word for a side to
side or a twisting motion and an
airplane moves side to side or yaws
around its vertical axis now I do want
to mention that yaw the airplane is not
the way we turn an aircraft I'll be
explaining this more in a future video
but it's important to remember that the
yaw axis is controlled by using the
rudder pedals and the reason we have
Rudder pedals is to maintain directional
control of the aircraft and the reason
we need to do this is because of
something called adverse yaw remember
what I said earlier about the ailerons
ailerons are what we're going to be
using to turn the airplane and we do
that by rolling around that longitudinal
axis when we rotate the Yol one aileron
moves up and the other aileron moves
down not only does this roll the
airplane but something else happens as
well anytime an aileron is lowered that
Wing has more drag on it and because of
this extra drag the airplane actually
yaws in the direction of that lowered
aileron this means that anytime you roll
the aircraft you should also be moving
the rudder pedals as well and Rudder
pedals are simple when you push the
right pedal the airplane yaws to the
right and when you push the left Rudder
pedal the airplane yaws to the left yaw
to the left yaw to the right
um sure anyway this means that in order
to keep the airplane aligned with its
direction of travel we must use the
rudder with the ailerons and this is how
you do that anytime you roll to the left
you should also be putting in a tiny
little bit of left Rudder as well and
when you roll right you should be
putting in a little bit of right Rudder
keep in mind this is also important when
you're rolling out of a turn so if I'm
rolling out of a left turn I have to use
right aileron to do that this this means
I actually need to use a little bit of
right Rudder to maintain that
directional control and you know you're
doing it right if the ball of your
aircraft is centered throughout the
whole maneuver if it's not step on the
ball to get the tail of the airplane
back where it needs to be boy you better
be stepping on that ball well he ain't
wrong get ready to hear that again and
that is how to control an airplane I
hope you enjoyed this lesson before you
watch the next one be sure to take the
free quiz down in the description to
make sure that you've retained all this
information
and don't forget to check out free pilot
training. net if you need that
endorsement and I'll see you in the next
episode see
you we going to learn you right